ظهور الرئيس المصري السابق حسني مبارك في
المحكمه مشهد لم يكن كثير من الناس يعتقد
انه ممكن في يوم من الايام ففي غضون سته
اشهر انتقل مبارك من قمه السلطه الى قفص
الاتهام ومحاكمته اذيعت على العالم اجمع
وقد وجهت للرئيس السابق تهم الفساد
واختلاس الاموال والاخطر من ذلك تهمه
اصدار اوامر تقضي بقتل المتظاهرين الذين
دعوا لاسقاط نظامه وبالرغم من الحراسه
المش التي كانت تفرض اثناء المحاكمات الا
ان ذلك لم يكن يحل دون اشتباك المعارضين
لمبارك خارج القاعه بما في ذلك اقرباء
الذين قتلوا خلال الثوره مع الموالين له
ومن المقرر يوم السبت ان يتم النطق بالحكم
في محاكمه الرئيس السابق ومن بين الضحايا
الذين قتلوا خلال الثوره الشاب حسين جمعه
حسين البالغ من العمر 31 عاما وهو معلم
مدرسه اصابته رصاصه في الصدر ويتمنى شقيقه
محمد ان يحكم على مب باقصى الاحكام
اعدام الحكم المردي لاسر الشهداء
والمصابين كما ازهقت ارواح تؤخذ ارواح ده
الاعدام مجدي فوده قائد مجموعه مؤيده
لمبارك يامل ان تبرئ المحكمه مبارك من
التهم الموجهه اليه ويقول فوده انه استطاع
ان يجمع 750 الف توقيع لدعوه التماس العفو
عن مبارك في حين انشات مجموعات اخرى على
فيسبوك مثل صفحه احنا اسفين يا رييس التي
ضمت اكثر من 24 الف مستخدم اتظلم ظلم رهيب
الفتره اللي مرت علينا فاحنا هنقف وفضيل
جنبه ونستمر في دعمنا للرئيس بكل ش الطرق
بكل ماتينا لان هدفنا هو اظهار
الحقيقه دعني انقل لك رساله واضحه من
الضحايا لا يوجد احد فوق القانون في مصر
الان المحامي خالد ابو بكر كان حضر كل
جلسات المحاكمه عن بعض من عائلات الذين
قتلوا خلال
الثوره اثناء المحاكمه هل رايت حسني مبارك
ياسف لما حدث
ابدا كنت اتخيل انه قد يعترف امام الناس
جميعا انه اخطا ولكن هذا لم يحدث وحتى
تعابير وجهه تقول لا لم اخطئ ومن خلال
المحاكمه لاحظنا انه قضى معظم وقته على
سريره المحمول وشعره لا يزال اسود مقارنه
برجل في الثمانينات من عمره ورغم وجود
صفحه اسفين يا ريس للموالين لمبارك فان
الرئيس السابق لا يبدو على استعداد لقول
اسف
لاحد